[MUSIC PLAYING]
TODD KERPELMAN: Hello.
I'm Todd Kerpelman for
the Developer Show,
and this is your weekly update
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
Over 50% of professional Android
developers now use Kotlin.
It's the fastest growing
language on GitHub,
and many new Jetpack
APIs and features
are going to be offered
first in Kotlin.
So to help you dive
deeper into Kotlin,
we're happy to announce a series
of community-driven events
focusing on the
potential of Kotlin
on all platforms called
Kotlin Everywhere.
To find out more about these
events and how to join in,
check out the
details in the post.
If you're building a
progressive web app,
you probably know that
on Android devices,
a Chrome system dialogue called
the mini-infobar will appear
at the bottom of
the browser screen,
prompting your users
to install your PWA.
While this can be helpful
in driving installs,
developers wanted more
control around when
they ask their users
to install their app.
So in Chrome 76, you can
prevent that mini-infobar
from appearing normally
and have it show up
at a time of your choosing.
To find out how, be sure to
see the details in the post.
At Google I/O this
month, the Android team
announced dark theme
support in Android Q,
a system-wide dark UI
mode toggled by the user.
And the good news for all you
Flutter developers out there
is that the Flutter team already
added support for the Android
dark theme back in February.
And you can enable it
in your Flutter apps
just by adding a property
to your widget tree.
Which property, you ask?
Well, you'll just have to
check out the post to find out.
Kubernetes applications
are enterprise-ready,
easy to deploy,
containerized applications
that can run in any
Kubernetes environment.
The Google Cloud
Platform marketplace
offers a wide range of solutions
as Kubernetes applications.
Everything from
databases to security
to developer tools and more,
with pricing agreement options
designed to meet your
enterprises' needs.
So to find out more,
be sure to check out
the details in the post.
Developer Student Clubs provide
thousands of student developers
around the globe the
tools and opportunities
they can use to grow as leaders,
advance their skills in Google
and open source tech, and
solve real-life problems.
If you're interested in solving
problems in your community
through tech and would
like to lead a student
community with
Google, you can apply
using the link in the
description below.
Hey, please remember to
like, subscribe and share.
I'm Todd Kerpelman for
the Developer Show.
Thank you for watching, and
we will see you next week.
I know kung, I
don't know kung fu.
[LAUGHTER]